As labelled on each graph, the horizontal axis represents the x values, and the
vertical axis represents the y values. From our equation, we know that even if
no wipers were made or x equals 0, Grant would still have to spend $1,200, which
would make y equal 100. That gives us the point 0,1200. x equals zero along the
y-axis here. We need to find the graph that intersects the y-axis at y equals
1,200. And that is this graph right here. The trend in the rest of the graph
makes sense as well. But every pair of glasses wipers that Grant makes, he
spends more money because our x value increases. From the equation, we can see
that as x gets bigger, y also gets bigger. So, the graph needs to move up and to
the right.